uh let me ask you about your family i
know you have uh a younger sister who's
is she quite a bit younger than you yeah
she's 10 years younger than me she's
here she's she's back there watching
she's backstage yeah uh and is she
interested in acting as well she's on
and off she told me the other day she
just wants she wants to know how she can
make a thousand dollars and
and i said why do you need that and she
goes well do you think i could get that
from doing a commercial or i have to do
tv or what do you think and uh i still
don't know why she needs it yeah that's
this disturbing part is i need a
thousand dollars now
when a 10 year old says that and don't
answer the phone they're looking for me
i need that money she's probably
backstage like this isn't funny i want
this
did you probably going through your
purse yeah right now she's like
i got 600 i'm 400 shorts
have you um now did you want to do
commercials when you were young did you
do commercials or want to do them i i
didn't do commercials but i when i was
like six i had this dream
to be in a pop-tart commercial because
when i was younger that was like the
cool commercial everyone was like
dancing and eating pop-tarts and singing
and i thought that that was just the
coolest thing ever but my dream never
came true and they stopped doing those
commercials and it was really sad
a tragic childhood yeah
no but you know but it's funny because
you do they create this world in
commercials when you're a kid that you
believe in but you know the reality
would be
that the the you know to make the pop
tart look good for the commercial it's
probably made of asbestos and they're
whipping you like smile smile
that's not a sponsor is it is pop tart
oh it is okay
my guess is they're very kind to the
people
the kids
when they make the ad
i'm sure it's fine it's a good product
um
what oh scream four i have to ask you
about scream four very successful people
love the screen franchise and this last
one people seem to really like yeah they
so far they seem to really love it
they're
the secret
of these seems to be first of all
they're so secretive about who the
killer might be that they even take it
to extremes wes craven will not even let
the cast know very much he keeps secrets
from them and he also i guess they're
really strict about who gets a script
who doesn't get a script yes how the
script is distributed it was it was
really uh stressful this whole time
because we shot last summer this whole
months till the movie comes out because
you have to keep the secret and even on
set they give you a script and your name
is on every page of the script so if you
lose it it's not only did the secret get
out but it's like oh and emma roberts
was the one that lost her script and i
remember going to set one day and i
dropped it and the pages just went
everywhere in this parking lot and i'm
literally running around the parking lot
picking up the pages like oh my god did
i lose any did i lose any and literally
the last 10 pages were
floating away and i was chasing them
around the parking lot for 10 minutes
trying to get them all just you're about
to get them a helicopter starts to land
you